the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I in some ways I won't be able to
compete with live demonstrations of
children from last week
but I will try to talk about adult
development and we will really sweep
through your minds and brains from when
you were not yet born until your going
to be in your 90s okay so so here's your
life from the beginning to to to the end
if you'd in different ways and we'll
touch number of different topics so you
know this question of it people talk for
a long time about this development that
one goes throughout one's life what
walks on four legs in the morning two
legs in the afternoon three legs in the
evening you know the answer to this
right people right they're crawling
they're standing up and then you get to
my age and we need an extra little prop
to move around successfully right and so
I started thinking about this at
different things matter to people at
different ages that there's different
priorities different ways of thought
Eric Erickson is often given credit for
trying to articulate that and we'll just
walk through it for a moment where he
said Oh at different ages in infancy
early childhood through school
adolescence young adulthood you know
people are dealing with different kinds
of issues and different developmental
tasks in front of them that your life is
a constant development not maybe as
dramatic as infancy where we saw last
time that children really see the world
differently but there's different
challenges in front of you at all ages
and so you know infancy you're deciding
who can you trust who can you love is it
a good world right and then the drama of
Oddi training independence you know how
much are you becoming a free agent in
the world early school we start to
interact with other children and and
play and make friendships and think
about social groups you know later in
schools as you're becoming more advanced
in terms of what you're learning in
school and more complex in terms of the
social networks that you're developing
the much-discussed it will come back to
this at the end period of a high anxiety
and drama of adolescence
then you know the something about young
adulthood you may have heard it recently
people been speculating that what used
to be the beginning of young adulthood
culturally at least in the US and maybe
Europe and industrialized parts of the
world that where's the 20s used to be
considered a decade of adulthood there's
now theories floating around an
impression floating around the 20's are
the new adolescents okay what do you
guys think you know everybody says oh my
20s I'm going to discover this I'm gonna
discover that but when I get to 30
that's when we're playing for keeps
is that is that is that I say what are
you wearing is that yeah well and parts
because you live longer on average or
you count on living longer and you do on
average live longer right for a person
who's counting on living 290 which many
of you are sort of another decade of
finding your way your 20s seems
reasonable right in a world where people
didn't live it nearly as long didn't
have as many options you know time you
finish college it's a roll you know or
many people didn't go to colleges roll
up your sleeves and get to adulthood so
there's an all these sort of magazine
discussions that are the 20s the new
teens okay in terms of whether people
feel they have responsibilities they
have to execute as a young adult and
then and this is a little bit timed also
that from you know a little bit
anachronistic because you know then
having a family although I think you
know we're much more thinking about
that's not necessarily the route for
everybody at all and then old age where
you give other people lots of advice
okay so we talk about brain development
from infancy to young adulthood a
cognitive stability and decline in
adulthood we've talked a little bit
about that talk a bit more alterations
and hemispheric specialization that come
with aging a bunch of remarkable results
about exercise in the brain all of us
want as we get older or just even when
you're younger maybe just a pill you pop
and you're all ready to go right that
would be the best it turns out there's
remarkable evidence about what physical
exercise does for the brain I'll show
that with you especially regards to
aging but at all ages ideas about how as
you get older your social and emotional
goals will tend to change
little bit about rewards and a little
bit about back to adolescents and some
rethought about what's going on in the
adolescent mind and brain so we know if
there's one thing about the brain that's
stunning and challenging to grasp it
empowers us to be humans it's its
complexity huge number of neurons
fantastic number of connections among
the neurons so there's just phenomenal
complexity that all starts right with a
single cell and how does the brain
become this dramatically complex organ
and how does it organize in the right
way to let you be an effective learner
and effective partner in your family and
so on so we start with the idea of
neurogenesis a magical word the neurons
being born they have to make this make
this crawled is a huge path for the size
of a neuron from the ventricular surface
the ventricle the fluid field space to
get to the place you're going to be in
the brain it's a huge adventure per
neuron cells dividing they're the
earliest neurons are existing about the
second embryonic week so that's when you
began to produce your neurons in your
brain by the seventh embryonic week so
you're just two months of pregnancy
you're producing 500,000 an estimated
500,000 neurons a minute we said a
neuron is kind of like a moderate
computer except unlike iPhones it can't
keep track of where you're going all the
time right but we said it's a it's a
moderate computer so 500,000 of those
every minute I mean is staggering right
that it all works out is staggering peak
by the 18th week you've mostly made all
the neurons through and if we're going
to make for the rest of your life except
in two brain regions and there's a big
debate in the last decade but about
another brain region I'll share those
with you but people have been taught for
many many many years in medical school
in college and graduate school that all
the neurons you get by the 18th week so
hang on to them through healthy living
and wise behavior right because you have
what you have right so don't lose them
but we'll talk about that you lose the
vast majority of them anyway naturally I
still recommend healthy living right
because you know perhaps from other
courses that the brain does this wild
thing that it excessively over produces
by man
massive scales the number of neurons and
the connections among the neurons and
then through use it gets rid of neurons
and gets rid of connections among
neurons right exactly the opposite way
if you built a building if you build a
building what do you do you construct
every bit of it you need and you're done
what you don't do is say I need a
two-story building so I'm going to do a
40-story building or a 90 storey
building and then knock off the stories
as they're not needed you say what while
why would I do that
right but the brain brilliantly makes
many more neurons and many more
connections on epic scales and then only
uses the ones that seem to be useful for
the functions of the brain and so for
that reason the number of the the
density of the neurons in the brain is
much higher in a two-year-old than in
you or it was much higher when you were
two than it is now
okay so at a two-year-old they have 55%
more gray matter density in the frontal
lobe than adults even at age five even
at age seven they're 10 percent more so
your constant from a peak around before
birth you're constantly shedding neurons
and their connections and keeping the
ones that seem to be effective somehow
now for many years people have said is
there neurogenesis in the adult brain is
everything you get before you're born
and that's pretty much it and there's
many reasons to be interested in that
one is just how does the brain work how
do people work the second is for
diseases like Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease and other diseases
we would love to replace neurons that
have died to help people do better so
can the brain make new neurons passed
before birth there's compelling evidence
in animals and some indirect evidence in
people to that neurogenesis dust
consider continue into adulthood
in the olfactory bulb and in us
particular part I'll come back to this
of the hippocampus a small part of that
the camp was called the dentate gyrus
everybody's pretty much agreement on
this for the moment which is kind of
interesting why those two areas amongst
all the areas in the brain what makes
them different that they can produce
neurons all throughout your life
and then about a decade ago Elizabeth
school of Princeton said oh you know
when I do the right kind of experiment I
see new neurons and the prefrontal
cortex of monkeys of you know infrahuman
primates that was a giant revolution
because they said wait a minute maybe if
prot you know monkeys are doing them
people might be doing at making neurons
throughout their life we just didn't
know that it's not so easy to measure
okay if you think about it the kind of
experiment to know for certain if a
human is making a new neuron is not so
easy because brain imaging is very far
from the single neuron level and even if
we saw a neuron how could we tell it's
new so and then there's you know Pascal
Ricci chess or big developmental
research or Yale said that what she
really thought was she really saw was
glia the glia are the other neuron their
cells in the brain not the neurons they
support the neurons everybody agrees
that you make glia all through your life
all right there's no debate about that
but glia are not the stuff of thoughts
and feelings neurons are so what's you
know what do we understand about that
whole story here's an unbelievable
experiment I think or it's really not an
experiment but it's a measurement so
here you know you're published in 2006
as one approach to asking do adults make
new neurons and so the nuclear bomb
tests that occurred during the Cold War
sent a carbon-14 into the atmosphere
from 1955 to 1963 until there was an
international Test Ban Treaty and then
these decreased and stopped but there's
a lot of nuclear bomb testing in the
late 50s and 60s that released carbon-14
into the atmosphere and that integrates
with DNA and forms a date mark for the
cell of a birth okay so this is not an
experiment we would want to do again
which they have you know atmospheric
nuclear testing and having nuclear stuff
floating around in the atmosphere right
but I'll tell you the bottom line and
I'll show you how they figured this out
what they figured out is looking at
people who died a few years ago that
non-neuronal cells are generated that
was found before glial cells are made
throughout your lifetime is the
inference from the finding but neurons
are not generated in adult neocortex the
commentary and the charcoal said no new
neurons for you okay that quite true we
know these two little areas in the brain
do it
but not in most of the brain and they
also looked at something called a bird
you brdu which is another way to take a
brain if you have it that you can marks
newly synthesized DNA so if you have the
brain directly to measure you have a
couple of measures of newly synthesized
DNA which will be the a marker of new
neurons so here's the fantastical
interesting they took people who are
born in different times took post mortem
samples and measured the cowbird 14
relative to what was expected the line
here is relative to what was expected by
the amount of carbon in the atmosphere
okay so that's it and here's what they
found if they look for somebody born
after 1963 they have in their neurons
exactly the amount that you would expect
if they made all their neurons around
around here and the decrease here didn't
affect the neurons at all the glia are
here which is kind of an average of here
and the rest of life so if you manage
the average age of the glia it was about
the average age love the life of the
person the carbon was being picked up in
the DNA because that's being made it's
being kept and being made but the
neurons all look like one value the
value that has to do with when you're
born all right so it's not changing the
number of neurons that are showing the
carbon-14 as if whatever you got at
Birth that's it I mean I don't hear
somebody born before 1963 having
essentially zero carbon that's being
showing up in their neuronal DNA and
having again the expected average glial
DNA is if glia kept going so this is
fantastic which is looking at the
carbon-14 in the DNA of neurons and glia
and people have passed away and saying
the carbon-14 dating looks like neurons
you get them all before you're born
that's it
glia you keep making and they can look
at it more directly by looking at this a
thing that shows you recent DNA again
showing you impressively the glia keep
making new glia with new DNA but not
neurons so the current conclusion the
field as far as anybody can tell is no
new neurons for you except in your
dentate gyrus and olfactory bulb now
here's something fantastic though it
appear
to exercise I'll just show you one
example in animals and humans there's
other thing exercise will pump up the
number of new neurons you make in the
dentate gyrus of the hippocampus and we
know the hippocampus is important for
memory so that's not a bad place to make
new neurons so you know that going to
exercise you know will strengthen you in
various ways but you never realized
unless you follow this line of work that
when you exercise you're enhancing the
number of new neurons that you're
producing in your dentate gyrus so
here's two here's a couple of ways
people have approached this so one way
is to measure cerebral blood volume how
does blood is in the dente and I'm going
to show you evidence that mice that are
allowed to exercise push up the blood
volume and that seems to go with direct
evidence of neurogenesis because you can
do that in the animals you can look at
sacrificed animals and then in human
some indirect evidence that exercises
again pushing up the blood volume in the
dentate and pushing up a little bit
memory abilities that go with that part
of the brain we can't go in and measure
neurons in the humans so here are mice
who exercise their didn't exercise they
measure the blood volume here in red is
the dentate part of the hippocampus you
can see it's a hottest spot for blood
volume and it's the only spark that
responds to to exercise so they had some
mice not get to exercise some bikes get
to exercise the blood volume increases
within the hippocampus selectively in a
small component of the hippocampus the
dent hrs exercise is pushing up the
blood volume now that's not direct
evidence about what's happening the
cellular level but they can sacrifice
these animals and show you that if they
look at this binding that goes with new
neurons with new DNA that's pushed up in
the exercise animals here's the
statistics you know here's the picture
okay so then the animals that can relate
directly or correlate directly more
blood volume and more new neurons being
going with more physical exercise in
humans they can measure the blood volume
and so they had some people do more
exercise some people less exercise
against the dentate gyrus selectively it
shows an increase in blood volume in
humans and now they give them a memory
test and it's not overwhelming but at
least in some cases the people who did X
who pushed up their blood volume also
pushed up a little bit their memory
performance so in humans it has to be
more indirect but all the data aligned
with the idea that exercise is pushing
up neuronal Genesis creation of new
neurons in one of the two regions that
everybody agrees we make new neurons the
dentate gyrus of the hippocampus so but
cells have to go incredible distances at
the cellular size neurons have to travel
to the intended location migration
occurs over many months including eight
months postnatally here's this neuron
following its little path to where it's
going to go the glial tracks following
molecular cues as to their ultimate
target location to get organized its
initial destination of function are
predetermined at the start of migration
people can measure things in these that
tell you where this is going to end up
it's programmed in these cells that
unless there's a something that blocks
them that they know where they're going
to go and make up different parts of the
brain and then they form synapses right
the part of where information is sent
from one neuron to another it occurs
throughout the brain but at different
rates in different areas so very early
you see it in spinal cord very late you
see it in higher cortical areas like
prefrontal cortex at the peak growth
there's an estimate these are all you
know gross estimates that there may be
you may be forming 1.8 million synapses
per second it's stunning
right 1.8 million synapses per second
and do you know how many molecules are
in average synapse by current
estimations a thousand there's a
thousand different molecules in a
synapse for it to do what it has to do
multiplied times 1.8 million per second
it's spectacular biology and then they
keep getting more and more until two
years and then you start just lose them
by a bit by by age 16 you'll have lost a
lot of them and so that people have this
idea we mentioned before that pruning
and selection that we over grow the
number of neurons number of connections
what stays is activity dependence or
this use it or lose it
neural Darwinism here's something
amazing there's an estimate and you know
that we lose 20 billion synapses per day
through adolescence 20 you know and
that's not a bad thing okay
that's not the worst behaving
adolescents doing the worst things they
can do that's the brain
you know getting rid of connections that
aren't useful
it's an incredibly interesting way to
construct a powerful brain is to get
everybody you could build a way over
build right and then illuminate the ones
that aren't powerfully useful and
another thing another marker of
development is myelination that's the
growth of the fatty sheath that
surrounds neurons that are extending
distances it insulates them and
accelerates a signal it looks like white
matter in the post-mortem brain what
happens through adolescence here's age
four to twenty two is that white matter
goes up and gray matter goes down so
quite interesting with the total brain
size from about sage six to about twenty
young adulthood most of you stays about
the same the total brain size what
you're doing is you're getting rid of
gray matter and you're enhancing white
matter you're getting rid of the neurons
that are non-productive and the synapses
that are non-productive and you're
increasing the strength with which
different parts of the brain can
communicate with one another through the
white matter and so here's the kinds of
pictures of this growth and some some of
the air parts of the brain that mature
latest by these kinds of measures of
getting rid of the overgrowth are in
prefrontal cortex and we've talked about
that before somet people are interested
in always in thinking about
developmental issues in the biology of
them and here's a kind of a stunning
finding and we don't know exactly how it
would relate to humans but I thought to
be interesting to share with you and
think about this just a little bit so
the title of the paper in science was
good memories of bad events in infancy
so we know from before and just every
common sense that fear is important for
the survival right so we started the
amygdala which seems essential for
learning what's to be feared
because what's to be feared is what
injures you or worst case could kill you
so the amygdala central for learn fear
and we know that one example of fear
conditioning that depends on the
amygdala would be a neutral stimulus
like an odor you know an odor that's not
particularly good or bad just an odor
and then a shock that makes it an
aversive stimulus so you pair them
through conditioning odor shock odor
shock so the odor predicts a shock now
they looked at young
and looked at attachment and here's what
they find kind of remarkably up to
postnatal day nine for these rats if
they exposed to the odors and the shocks
here's what they do they know through
pairings odor shock odor shock odor
shock right here comes the odor here
comes the shock they still approach the
odors that's what's in this grass up to
nine days the rats
the Weisse right who are still
approaching this odor even though it
will lead to a shock but on the tenth
day just one day later it completely
reverses and they avoid the odors to
predict the shock a complete reversal so
they keep going to the odors with the
shock and then a tenth day the pups
stopped going there and what they also
find is this if they look at metabolic
activity in the amygdala for the nine
days is the same for the odor and the
shock or a neutral odor it's not
selective to what's to be feared and the
10-day old here's a big response in the
amygdala for the odor that predicts the
shock for the fearful learning to know
what's scary and dangerous and dangerous
so how do people think about this well
this is an animal experiment up to nine
days we can't really know how it relates
to people but the speculation was this
and maybe there's something to it on a
different scale in people why would an
animal approach something injurious up
to the amygdala seems to get more mature
and then avoid what's injurious why
would that happen in such a predictable
evolutionary determined you know way and
the hypothesis is this that if you're a
very helpless newborn you have to go to
things no matter what okay because
you're so dependent on things in your
environment to survive but at some
moment you mature enough that you say no
thank you
if it's going to be shocking and painful
I'm going to avoid it okay you become
kind of independent in that sense and in
a concrete sense and so the author said
well could it be helpful for newborns to
know what no matter what approach a
caregiver you know not not respond to
that are negative because you need the
care because you're so dependent and now
this is super speculatively a thing
that's been noted is that even in
families where there's unfortunate
tremendous abuse for a young child the
abuse victims so commonly remain
powerful loyal to their parents is this
kind of a mechanism that mixes up
attachment and fear
all right especially when you're young
and can't separate them out so well so
it's a huge leap from the mice to the
people but it's a mechanism that we can
understand might be involved and how
attachment and fear can have unusual
relationships with one another all right
you you can't avoid reading in the
newspapers or seeing on your computer
screen discussions about the deficit and
older people like me demanding a lot of
medical care that's paid for by the
wages you're gonna get in a couple years
right okay all right all right I mean
that's how I look at it we're good so ah
all right Abbi I'm you know all right so
you are entering a world we're all
entering a world where the changing ages
the demography of our society is
spectacular Japan is ahead of us in this
a little bit the rest of the world is
following and China is going to be
unbelievable when it happens on scale
but the United States right now okay
right now and here's why for most of
human history the average life
expectancy was up to 20 years old that's
why you had to be an adult right because
a 20 kolya who knows how much time I
have right better do my adult things
right and it wasn't that people some
people live for a long time this is
really interesting it wasn't that
everybody perished by 30 it was that
some people live to 60 70 80 90 but many
people fell ill too many diseases that
are now readily cured so the average age
was 20 1800s it became the 30s as you
know just a couple hundred years ago in
all of human history by 2000 the average
first in the u.s. lived till 77 by 2010
78 so we're having a spectacular growth
in the proportion of humans in our
society who are living a long long time
which is a wonderful thing right okay
but it's radically changing the world we
live in and the world for those people
who are older as well so for example 100
year old people there's 50,000
in the US which is triple what there was
time ago and it's expected to be a
million people in the US who are a
hundred years and older by 2050 which is
in your lifetime okay a million people
in the US alone who will be a hundred or
older and maybe 50% of girls born in
2000 will live for a century all right
spectacular changes are occurring right
this moment okay the baby boom
generation huge numbers of us are
approaching you know retirement and the
kind of medical support that gets
heavier when you get older on average
huge numbers of us how is there changing
one way it's changing is that families
often have and you might hear this issue
of families feeling that there's
Sandwich Generation they're taking care
of their children and the elderly and
you can bet if you have parents who are
living to 120 you're doing that okay all
right giant effects on education pension
work financial markets I mean these are
epic societal effects so you're hearing
the discussion now about how the u.s. is
going to deal with this so there used to
be kind of an old model and then even
this is not that old this is from the
mid-1950s you know where you your job
was to you know go to college have a
career have a mate take care of a kid
retire at 65 and put your feet up on the
desk right but all of a sudden if
everybody's living not everybody but
huge numbers of people are living till
say 70 80 90 100 many in pretty good
health
not everybody we wish for but many
pretty good health that's a
fantastically different thing 65 is no
longer there tire moment and you're glad
you made it 65 is something like the
halfway point of your potential work
life all right 20 to 60 60 to 100 you
know something like this right okay
it's an unbelievable change you cannot
overestimate how it's changing the world
around you and how it will affect the
economics and politics of the world that
the rest of us will be in you for many
years there's about 10% of the
population over 65 now in 20 years one
out of every four people will be over 65
but current estimates so we're going to
let whatever President we want okay and
older people go vote a lot more than
younger people you can change that but
that's how it is
so let's talk
about adult development I can tell you
that if you compare adult development
for very little is understood from 20 to
80 almost all the research is taking
something like college students and
something like 80 year olds and
comparing them so this is pretty much
minimal informations available about
everything between 20 and 80 but we'll
look at what we can and one of the
things we're talking about for a moment
is the two kinds of studies we can look
at for development this could be about
infants but we're going to talk about
adults cross-sectional versus
longitudinal so cross-sectional is I
look at you as 20 year olds I look at
eight some 80 year olds in the Boston
community compare them that's very
different than looking at you at 20 and
seeing you at 80 right because that's
much more controlled that's you with
everything that's special in particular
about you at 20 and 80 when you go get
people who are twenty year olds for one
place and eighty year olds from another
cross-sectional study that's going to
you know have all the differences that
go with those cohorts so what are the
what do we see in these kinds of things
sorry so here's here's some measures
you've seen this kind of system before
for things like working memory speed of
processing long-term memory gives people
in their 20s people in their 80s a ski
slope of a decline here's things like
knowledge of vocabulary and that stays
more studies the crystallized fluid
distinction you've already heard about
before so what are the strengths and
limitations of cross-sectional versus
longitudinal studies so for
cross-sectional studies they're fast if
you're a scientist like a graduate
student who has to do a PhD thesis is in
the Maiar six or seven years okay you
can go to an experiment with 20 year
olds and 80 year olds and have a
conclusion if you're a graduate student
who would have to test this class of 20
and come back to you in 60 years from
now and see how you're doing all right
it's gonna be slow progress okay so
that's why the overwhelming amount of
evidence is cross section the problem
with it is cohort effects we discussed
for example that IQ scores go up year by
year throughout the world so you're not
really comparing equal things in terms
of educational opportunities nutrition
exposure to information on the internet
a 20 year old and an 80 year old
have lived through different worlds so
it's all mixed up in the measurements
not just age it's different worlds that
people have lived in longitudinal
studies are painfully slow they're more
accurate because you're looking at
change within a person you're holding
all the world things constant you have
one other weird thing which is you get
practice effects if you test somebody in
the same test
not if 60 years apart you don't get much
but maybe three or four years apart you
take a test twice you get better at it
so that's a problem with longitudinal
effects where you retest somebody so
there's been a few studies have looked
at relatively short-term longitudinal
and cross-sectional data and here's the
ski slope on the values of a fluid
intelligence things and it's just made a
bit milder by a longitudinal design but
not dramatically different so it's not
the case of longitudinal studies the
people used to think all these
longitudinal studies are overestimating
that especially if you're older you like
that thought yeah it's a messed up study
approach but unfortunately
cross-sectional ones just diminish the
difference a little bit so people have
said though there's an interesting
trade-off what's the trade-off then I'll
ask you for a moment between most of you
are like eighteen to twenty-two a lot
bracket at 17 to 25 right most of you is
that fair okay okay what advantage do
you have versus somebody in their mid
50s like me and what disadvantage do you
have in some global sense oh that was
that was painful yes yeah the answer was
you guys are physically able okay all
right that that would be true okay yeah
there's there's not many Olympian
sprinters who are in their mid 50s right
okay all right so how about in terms of
cognitive things so we just said for
speed of mental processing it's good to
be 20 and then you thirty-year-olds a
little slower 40 rose a little slower 50
is 6070 okay every decade a little bit
slower for speed of mental processing
but there's one thing that's an
advantage with time for cognition what's
the advantage sorry
experience thank you oh yes okay yes you
get to with over time you learn stuff
especially if stuff that you're you know
you're exposed to a lot rights so time
is a trade-off between with it in
adulthood you lose some speeded
capacities you gain some specific
knowledge or experience and so they
looked at studies like these air traffic
controllers in Canada where and this is
very relevant because people are
constantly thinking about what
especially now air traffic controllers
are in the news more than they want to
be right you right you see them there
unfortunately napping they're playing
movies some of them mmm sure it's a tiny
minority but worrisome if you're a
member of the flying public okay so
here's another question what age should
you tell somebody well I think you know
we don't need you to be an air
controller anymore because you're not
with it enough for us to feel safe right
so people are probing this all the time
so air you know so here the average
retirement age in the u.s. is 55 in
Kenneth's 65 there's one more correct
than the other and so here's what they
found when they looked at air traffic
controllers age influence processing
speed but not task performance so what
we're thinking is but older people
aren't better but they're not worse
maybe there's a trade-off between speed
and experience and it kind of evens out
until some age where it will no longer
even out 118 pilots 40 to 69 they would
took quite place in flight simulators
tested three times across three years so
longitudinal design in a flight
simulator the older pilots were worse
the first time they did it now some time
is passing but then they outperform the
younger pilots in years two and three
that is ones they had some experience
with the new situation they could apply
presumably their prior experience but
the very first time they did it when
they have to use their fluid
intelligence to figure out what's going
on they were worse so you can see some
trade-offs between raw processing speed
and flexibility that goes with young
adulthood and some degree of knowledge
and expertise that's gained over time
it's a trade offs on these things how
about a memory declarative memory that
we talked about everyday memory I'll
show you in a moment there's mild steady
decline in healthy aging severe and
Alzheimer's
implicit memory we talked about that you
know can be more steady across ages but
let me focus on explicit memory of
declarative memory um we're going to
figure out what's whether
projectors washing these things out so
much but here's a slide you don't have
to see very much no long-term memories
performances going down you know quite
sharply year by year as you get older
but here's something that was a huge
surprise from brain imaging a huge
surprise and that thing that if you
didn't have rein imaging you wouldn't
even concede that it could have existed
so many studies have done brain imaging
as people perform various kinds of tasks
memory tasks in this case with young
adults and older adults and what they
found unexpectedly was this that young
adults would typically activate one side
of the prefrontal cortex typically in
regards to whether it was a verbal or
spatial so here's young adults mostly on
one side mostly on one side mostly on
one side mostly on one side healthy
older adults in good health
characteristically turned on both sides
of the brain as they were performing
these memory tasks so you wouldn't have
known that if you didn't have imaging
because who could have thought about
that right so then there was a little
bit of a debate in the field where the
fact that adults were turning on both
sides of their foot Hema spheres whereas
adults were just picking one or just
using one was that a good thing or a bad
thing so people said well it's a bad
thing because maybe if you get older you
lose your specializations and you're
using the wrong stuff okay it's as if I
need my physics book and I'm gonna grab
my chemistry book well just grab your
physics book right okay right
just grab the run right thing why why
are you getting other stuff that's not
relevant and could mess you up and slow
you down so some people said you're sort
of losing the specialization of peak
young adulthood you're leaking brain
activity in the wrong places it's yet
another sad sign of getting older here's
an alternative one well you get older
but maybe you get some compensatory
mechanisms you realize at some level in
your brain that you can't do what you
couldn't when you were 20 and you make
up for that by somehow using two sides
of your brain instead of one
zhenia so that would be a good thing
right so how would you decide that how
would you decide whether using the two
sides of your brain when you're an older
adult is a helpful thing part of the
solution to keeping your cognition going
or is it part of the problem of losing
long-term memory abilities as you get
older they're declining how would you
decide that there's kind of an easy
answer sorry
you what
yes well yeah should we split the yeah
this is a suggestion which you think
older people split their brains and see
how they're doing yeah yeah all right
well older people are their long-term
memories not that bad there you said it
yeah
so here's he was the USD approach it
seems reasonable they say amongst older
people some people do better and worse
in terms of the memory does better
memory would go with using two sides or
one side right and what was found here's
one example here's young people using
one side of the frontal cortex as they
perform a memory task
here's older people whose memory was not
so good here's older people whose memory
was good and here's a similar finding so
the suggestion was that older people who
used both frontal cortices we're
actually doing better they were having
less of an effective age on cognition so
the answer seems to be it's a good thing
and if you're older or you somehow
compensate for some of the decrease in
long-term ability by applying more
neural systems to support your
performance okay so now what are some
factors that I mean older adults are
really interested not about 30 years you
might be but older adults are really
interested in you know what can I do to
keep myself going since I'm going to
live to be 80 90 or 100 with any just a
little bit of luck how can I keep my
quality of life high in terms of
cognition and mental abilities so one
thing that people have found is that on
average higher education is correlated
with and there's many interpretations of
this better cognitive abilities and less
likelihood of getting Alzheimer's or
getting Alzheimer's if you're going to
get it at an older age so that's kind of
interesting that's a good to go to
college good to keep being educated in
some sense it doesn't have to be formal
but formal education correlates with
that now here was a surprise and now you
tell me what it is so how would that
work
how would sitting there and listening to
me really carefully right now give you
an extra decade of cognitive ability
when you're 80 okay
all right now I've got your attention so
how would that work biologically like
you know is education kind of going in
your brain and saying you know we're
we're knocking all these things in there
keeping them here and we're not gonna
let you have any injury when you're 40
or 50 how does that work okay so I'm
going to tell you one more piece
information which is this and you tell
me what you think so the other thing
that that we know is there's evidence
that once you get the diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease then the higher the
more educated you are the faster you
decline and I don't think the story is
all done yet because people are
complicated but this is this is the
current evidence so how do you interpret
that so here's the interpretation the
interpretation is more education gives
you more mental tools what people will
call cognitive reserve you have more
things going for you like maybe the
ability to use two hemispheres that will
protect you as something like some brain
injury happens over time like an
Alzheimer's disease or other causes of
slowed or diminished cognition and old
age that will help you you have more
tools with which to keep operating
successfully but once Alzheimer's
disease become severe enough in the
brain that those tools are no longer
available to you then the more educated
you are the more you plummet because you
know everything is done so we now know
something and obviously we're busy
Alzheimer's disease and this is
compelling evidence for this starts in
your brain about 15 years before you get
the diagnosis about and it could be more
than that that's how far we can track it
back by brain imaging so if an adult is
diagnosed with Alzheimer's at 70
somewhere around 55 something has
started that will you know will
ultimately be injury enough to be lead
to dementia and Alzheimer's disease
and that's why there's such a big
emphasis on early identification because
it's very hard to treat a brain that had
a lot of injury you want to you want to
catch the people at 55 or 60 so we also
know that lifelong cognitive activity
activity is good conscientious which we
talked about that and here again comes
exercise okay so so they took a study
this is this is now a random assignment
study finally a full-on experiment where
they took relevant Airi people people
were not exercising over 60 and assigned
them to two groups an aerobic training
group who is did walking and swimming so
some real exercise and a non-arabic
group who did toning and stretch
so they were they thought they were
special they were active but they
weren't doing the aerobic exercise and
and they didn't do it a phenomenal
amount of time an hour a day a few times
a week for months it's not a brutal
exercise schedule what happens it's kind
of amazing what happened these are
healthy people but not very active
what's shown here in the red bars are
the cognitive performances after the
after the exercise of the healthy older
people and blue bars are the people who
did the stretching and toning not the
aerobic exercise so very substantial
gains and cognitive abilities from a few
months of moderate exercise and in the
brain both by functional MRI and by
structural MRI in gray matter and white
matter physically measurable changes in
the brain for the group that did the
aerobic exercise a couple times a week
you know for a few months compared to
the group that did a sedentary access
the less active exercises that's amazing
brain changes cognition changes again
not no pill you can pop and you're
making new neurons and you're dentate
gyrus to boot right so it's kind of you
know now all of us want the easy out but
exercise is the most compelling story
for keeping your brain optimized that we
know now here's a remarkable thing so
exercise we kind of get actually if you
think about it we don't know the
mechanism at all okay I mean you know
you're running around like this now how
is that pushing up your neurons in your
brain but here's something very
psychological that's kind of stunning
and the first I almost didn't believe it
when I read it but there's been a few
other studies that have supported this
we often exercise is something real
attitudes even a psychology of course
attitudes are just kind of they're just
attitudes okay so look at this and then
you can think about this so they're
lipped in a longitudinal study of 400
people over 400 in Baltimore
longitudinal study of Aging they started
under 50 but they've kept going with
them they gave them a questionnaire on
attitudes about aging so they said our
older people for example more
absent-minded or less intelligence and
some people are you know say oh oh my
gosh older people are very absent-minded
they're very less intelligent other
people think it's just a milder thing
people vary in their estimates of how
severe these changes are in old age then
they measured something very concrete
and real the number of cardiovascular
events
like stroke or heart attack over the
next 38 years okay so this is a real
physical measurement this is an attitude
how powerful is an attitude well it's
kind of stunning unbelievably powerful
in some ways we don't know if it's the
attitude or something correlated but
here's the percent with cardiac strokes
or heart attacks here's the people who
had negative age stereotypes and here's
the paper who had positive age
stereotypes so one always has to be
worried about this a chicken and egg
issue you know maybe if you've had a lot
of strokes and heart attacks you're not
so optimistic about your old age right
but they were measuring these things at
the beginning they were very similar so
that they weren't starting out with
different health problems so something
about attitudes seems to chip in to the
most core aspects of physical health but
none of us understand the mechanism yes
good that's a good so the questions how
about family history it could be mixed
into that yes yeah that's a very good
point then it's not just attitudes right
or it could be not attitudes at all okay
as I sew here and here's the concept
that regardless of your age but age is
one of the most powerful pieces of the
story when your time is limited people
focus on social goals related to
emotional meaning and emotional
satisfaction and less related to
knowledge acquisition that depending on
the moment of your life on average you
know when you're an adolescence and
you're in college and graduate school
and you're beginning your residency or
becoming a you know junior partner at a
law firm you're in an age of huge
information acquisition what you want to
know is what do I need to know to do
something important significant valuable
in my life right right you're sitting
here acquiring knowledge colleges you
know four years of acquiring knowledge
in terms of classrooms and majors right
you guys do other things too but the
number one mission is acquire that
knowledge or now when you get older you
know you don't really want it so much
information anymore and maybe what
you're much more interested in is how
you regulate your feelings how how
positive can you make your life all
right not by being adventurous taking
risks clean all this kind of stuff by
finding a way towards happiness I'm
going to show you a bunch of research
that
suggest it young adulthood is full about
acquisition of information through
adventure an old age you regulate your
remote that you switch on average your
focus to regulate your emotions in
positive ways and so sometimes people
will call that wisdom although you could
you could just say it's different things
for different ages are desirable and
part of the support came from the
following result which has been found
many many many times but was kind of
stunning when it was first reported so
this is where people were asked how
happy are you are you satisfied with
your life so here's younger adults 18 to
50 basically about half of them said
they're very satisfied but it zooms up
if you're older how many people are
satisfied with a standard of living 40
if you're younger 60 if you're older
frequency of depression for example
never Liz Liz Liz Pacific often higher
for younger people more frequent
thoughts about suicide everybody measure
you can make if we give you a
questionnaire like this on average for
20 year olds or 30 year olds you report
more unhappiness
okay then older people on average of
course it varies okay but that's kind of
a surprise maybe or not okay and that's
everybody has found that not not a
surprise
ah well we'll come back to this again
yes just because you say you're happier
doesn't mean you're happier yeah we
don't have a better way than that though
okay yeah okay we can't say oh you think
you're happy but you'd be so happy if
you were a Caltech you need me just so
happy yeah hi you know this is one of
the measures you know I'm a brain
measurer so I like objective the
measures I think if a person tells you
they're happy they probably are there's
certain moments I know when people tell
you well we'll see who knows I agree
with you it's a concern so here's the
thought that motivation and goals are
set by temporal context that time is
perceived as limited and all this will
come that the older you get the more you
focus on positive things in the world
and what makes you happy as a thought is
to focus on positive things and ignore
the negative so how true might this be
experimentally so they had students
authors it really washed out capture
these special moments the same ad and
this one says capture so capture the
special moments and this one says
capture the unexplored world so if
you're an information seeker which is
better the unexplored world or the
special moments which is better on
explore world write your 20 year old
unexplored is awesome all right young
people prefer this ad
older people prefer the special moments
special moments we emotionally
satisfying right okay here's another one
they show you pictures of a positive and
a negative expression it flashes away
and there's a dot left and you simply
put if the dot appears on the right you
push your right hand button if the dot
appears on the left you push the
left-hand button
it's simply pushing to a dot but the dot
is in the place where you just saw
either a negative or a neutral face and
what they find is for younger people
they're about as fast whether the dot
appears where the neutral or negative
face was they don't really care for the
older people they're much faster if the
dot appears where the positive phase had
just been as if their attention was
locked to the positive face oh the dot
appears there I'm ready to go block to
the positive face of the dot appear here
we go oh oh oh and you shift your
attention and that takes extra time so
you're locked to the positive when you
see a positive and a negative face
here's another one where you're asked on
your in a positive and negative car
options things that are good or bad
a car this line goes up this line goes
down younger people focus born the
negative options relative to older
people who focus more on the positive
options here's another one you show
pictures of happy scenes or neutral
scenes or negative scenes this is the
graveyard young people's memory for
positive negative and neutral things
they remember emotional things better
let's go to the older people look at
this line way up here that's memory for
the positive scenes and here's the
negative scenes do you see the focus on
the positivity and the sort of lack of
interest in the negative stuff right for
young people equally interesting if it's
positive or negative for older people
much more interesting and sticking in
your memory if it's positive and not
sticking in your memory that's negative
so one of the big questions is is just
simply about getting older and I'm going
to ask you to think back if I can to
your last days in high school your last
days in high school for those last days
and I'm sure it will vary depending on
your experience in different ways were
you primarily interested in getting that
last little bit of information about us
history or calculus haven't you might
have been that could be the critical bit
of information that will make college
work out or or did you have a sudden and
this kind of embarrassing when you're 16
17 18 enhanced sense of nostalgia oh
this is the last time the three of us or
the six of us or the eight of us or the
two of us will be together then we're
spreading across the world to go to
different colleges nobody had that
feeling okay it's kind of embarrassing
when you're 18 because you're not
supposed to say that kind of stuff
alright and it will happen to you at the
end of college for most of you most of
the time I remember senior year crept up
on us in college and we started college
in oh my gosh there's a last year we're
together and seem very emotionally
important okay all right so age your
time so if this is it simply a tree a
time so they did experiments where they
asked people are you focusing on you
know adventure and content are you
focusing on emotion and satisfaction
when you're about to move from one city
to another people wanted to spend time
with people they really cared about and
they were not interested in getting new
information more to more serve tragic
studies if people are near death and
they ask this question of course time
with people not acquiring information
but here's another one inner-city gangs
study in Los Angeles inner-city gangs
that are involved in violence much more
interested in time with people than in
information and you know partly that
goes with what is viewed from the
outside you know sometimes is kind of
the insane loyalty that inner-city gang
members have for one another
it's because they're so focused given
their situation on this relations with
the other people in their group compared
to everything that's rational about a
safe you know growing up right okay so
it's not and tragically you know if you
ask member inner-city gangs how long
they think they'll live they often tell
you not very long I'm counting on out
living very long right so it's not
whether you're 20 or 60 or 80 it's how
long you sense time is in front of you a
temporal horizon so here's one study
where the I had a hand in when we took
older and younger people and put them
inside MRI and showed them positive
neutral and negative pictures here's a
couple different points when they said
how intense is this picture look at
younger people positive neutral and the
negative are really intense look at this
goes down so the older people as they
see the pictures experienced by their
own report the negative pictures is
being less intense all right they're
sort of down pulling the negative and if
we ask their memory
here's younger people positive and
negative things neutral things save for
positive a negative look at older people
much more focused in memory retaining
and memory the positive and not so much
the negative and if we look in their
amygdala which we know is the structure
that's essential for how emotion
modulates the formation of memory here's
young people here's a positive picture
here's a negative picture who's a
neutral picture so emotion counts
positive and negative count about the
same look at older people
here's positive and here's negative okay
so this partly addresses the question
like for some people like older people
pretending they're positive well it
doesn't look like that right this is
amygdalas they're looking at it I mean I
don't know if they're the middle that
can pretend to look at the positive
right so here's the good news for you
what will happen is you get older on
average is that for whatever reason it
happens
we don't really know why we you will
focus more and more on the positive
things in your life and you'll feel
better for that on average so that's a
kind of quiet satisfaction now I'm
focusing on the positive that's the Zen
satisfaction let's talk about fantastic
satisfaction reward system right when
you really want to do something because
it's really wonder if it's going to feel
so wonderful the reward system let me
tell you a little bit about what we
understand about that it involves
dopamine it's a critical
neurotransmitter starts in the ventral
tegmental area of your brainstem and
that project is something called the
nucleus accumbens an inferior portion of
the basal ganglia and this is reward
central if you love something from opera
to chocolate to video games this turns
on every experiment that people have
ever done shows in humans if something
really turns you on this area really
gets turned on all right
I mean what's more powerful for us than
what we find deeply emotionally
rewarding this is that reward system and
the dopamine runs from there they're a
bit and look at how cells responds I'm
going to show you an example from
monkeys where we could look at single
cells and that and then brain imaging
back to people so here's the experiment
of monkeys and there's a message in this
that's both biologically true and I
think compelling about human life all
right so so biologically true is the
science that compelling about life is a
story right so here's the experiment the
monkey sits there and gets various cues
different visual things that tell them
what's coming up let's pretend this is a
cue that something wonderful is coming
up highly desired food right so they
they recording electrically while the
animal sees this there's waiting for it
what we can call the anticipation period
and now here comes the reward and here's
something sort of deep I think about
reward and learning and people and
things like this so here's the neurons
firing or
this is a this is some of the neurons
firing in the ventral tegmental area so
right now they're just sitting there
look here comes the reward here's our
and boom dopamine is released okay
the dopaminergic cells are firing at
crazy they're getting food they really
want we're thrilled we're hungry and
we're getting something
not much more rewarding than going to
happen when you're really hungry okay
now they predict the arrival with the
cue that you saw a meaningless stimulus
and look what happens when do these
neurons fire not for the food arriving
but for the visual signal that predicts
the food will come what's delicious for
the brain is the anticipation of
something that's rewarding and this
morning when I was think about slept
sure I think in my life how most always
I mean you might save us think about
experiences you've had that you look
forward to at almost the most delicious
part you might say it's the anticipation
of something delightful often the event
itself is more mixed and post climatic
anti-climatic than you would have
thought is that so is that fair okay I
mean I think there's nothing better than
like I'm anticipating something
wonderful then the event can be
wonderful but often it's a little more
complicated right that anticipation is
like pure joy because your dopaminergic
system is firing freely away and it
protests also so you get the visual
signal that oh the rewards coming up
okay here it is here comes the food the
food doesn't come look at the silence
these cells are protesting you know
because they didn't get what they
expected to get okay so it's very
compelling that the reward in you occurs
not even so much for the reward itself
but the anticipation of the reward is
where it's biologically occurring when
you can anticipate and Counting it
correctly so in humans it's harder to
deliver not impossible food in the
scanner so that a very simple thing is
done for reward which is offering people
money so in a given trial in a scanner
you might see a meaningless queue like
this but you learn that this box
predicts that at the end of this trial
you do many trials you're going to get
$1 another one might be $0.10 another
one they might take away $1 okay so this
is like a good one to get like I'm gonna
get $1 just sitting here I'm gonna get
$1 okay okay it's not huge it's not the
biggest reward in the world but it's
something for you just laying in a
scanner doing nothing umm and here's
what happens your nucleus accumbens gets
activated this where dopamine flows from
the ventral tegmental area
when you anticipate a reward this is not
be this is not when the reward comes is
when you're anticipating the reward
here's another picture that is most its
most powerful for when people anticipate
a gain a reward and less responsive when
people anticipate a loss so it's about
gains then the same system projects to
the inferior parts of your frontal lobe
so now we're moving into the neocortex
and that part of the brain seems to
respond most powerfully if you get the
reward so this is really interesting a
part of you burn the response to the
anticipation the dopaminergic reward
system and then another part of their
brain the response not whether you
anticipate it but sometimes they trick
you and they say we're going to give you
$1 in the gulps we're not giving it to
you okay this part of the brain seems to
register the receipt of the reward or
not so a separation of the brain between
the anticipation reward and the response
to whether you get the reward or not
older people when they look at these
kinds of similar reward paradigms they
respond they're less responsive to
potential loss but equally responsive to
potential gain as young adults so that's
exactly responding to positive things
and showing less of a response to
potential negative things so let's
switch to adolescence we're going to
focus on adolescence namelessly for the
next ten minutes pretty you know you
just got through that okay so let's
reflect back for the last couple years
and they make the experiments because
they want to put children into it a
little bit more vivid here's pirates
ears not much reward here some reward
here's a lot of reward okay in the
scanner and your children or adolescents
or young adults and they look in the
nucleus accumbens this is a reward
region and look who's firing like crazy
adolescents okay teenagers but they're
not firing like right to see in the
frontal cortex so this is very
speculative these are partly just wide
stories but once hypothesis is this and
we're going to say in a minute more
about this adolescence is a really
interesting period because it's not only
when you're deciding like who you are in
the world in many ways independently
it's also worrisome Lee for parents
grandparents cousins
siblings the period in life when people
are most likely to put themselves at
great risk and one version of that is
that the subcortical reward areas are
developing way faster than the cortical
areas that control and regulate your
behavior okay so you this goes with the
stereotype which is probably as unfair
as any other Serio type of the
out-of-control teenager right okay but
imagine if it were true that your reward
system is very turned up for and your
cortical control system we're not yet
caught up to the adult level well that
would make you a little bit more likely
to do adventuresome things right because
the reward is powerful and the control
of your thoughts about how to approach
that or reject that reward are less
powerful so ah so here's some things to
think about and people worry about for
adolescents 40% of adult alcoholics
report having initial alcoholism between
15 and 19 between 16 and 20 both sexes
have at least twice our slice of life
between accidents than drivers between
20 and 50 twice the accidental rape
adolescents more likely to engage an
impulsive sexual behavior of multiple
partners annually three million
adolescents contract with sexual
transmitted diseases so lots of things
that are risky behaviors occur with high
frequency in a demonstrable way on
average among adolescents okay young
kids don't drive yet 20 year olds are a
bit more mature when they're driving so
part of this is again attitudinal here's
here's a question that people were asked
about future perspectives they were
asked
I would rather save my money for a rainy
day than spend it on something fun right
now okay ah in your 20s a little bit but
you know when you're 11 - but you know
11 - that's growing but you'll keep the
dollar but you know the younger you are
in your teenage years the more like who
wants to wait let's do it now okay all
right so moving from something fun to
something experimental um let's put
together a couple last theme so here's a
thing we did before several times in
this class creating false memories and
you remember the way that they create
false memories in the laboratory is that
pick a word they don't present to you
like sweet then they asked many students
to say what words go with that word like
sour or candy or sugar they present you
this list and then they test you for
this word that was not presented and
people often imagined incorrectly do
they hurt or saw this word right we've
done that a couple of times it's a way
to show the illusory memories and then
why we understand it is basically this
your memory your mind mostly thinks
about the essence of things not the
details of things the essence of things
was everything is sweet the details were
the specific words in the list okay so
let's look at older adults versus
younger adults 80 year olds versus 20
year olds and exactly this experiment
older adults had many more false
memories and they perform less well so
here's to a scary extent the healthy 7
year olds here's their real memories
here's their false memories that's dead
even okay
here's young people having lots of false
memories but not as many as older people
and having more correct memories so
older adults have more false memories
because they're encoding the gist a lot
but they're losing the specifics does
that make sense okay then you're really
vulnerable to a false memory children
you might think well what do they know
right children have less false memories
than you do you would have had less more
false memories at age five than you
would right now which is kind of amazing
if you didn't do the experiment you'd
imagine children will be totally
confused they get a big list of words
with sweet on the list I don't know yeah
sure right okay now a five-year-old
that's better than a seven does better
than 11-year old does better than a 20
year old why why do this a five-wheel
have less false memories in their
circumstances well we understand that to
be the price of having a mind that
understands a lot of gists
as you become older you understand
what's important what counts it's not
the little details it's the big concepts
right so here's an example of for
example how well people can relate words
across sentences and that grows from 6
to 9 and that's what we want you don't
want to read word word word you want to
say what's the point
of the sentence right okay that process
of saying I don't care about the detail
I care about the concept the gist of the
concept it's like the chess players you
shed the digit specific details to gain
the overall knowledge advantage but the
five-year-old is not making the big
picture they're just getting the little
details so they're less prone for the
illusory memories and you can't see that
but what this is just showing that when
it comes to think organizing memories
you see that a develop across a
childhood okay last couple of things
because when I heard this a few years
ago conference I was so surprised by
these findings and I've been around long
enough I don't get as surprised as often
as I used to but it's kind of really
interesting it's a total twist and you
can you can make a judgment call about
how to interpret it but here's the
experiments in the data so again we have
this picture that everybody likes
because it fits with the stereotype
right which is the teenager out of
control their dopamine is going up there
and they're sitting you know let's go
have let's do a lot of inappropriate
things because it'll be rewarding okay I
know everybody's against it but you know
all right so that's a stereotype and
probably there's something true about
that if you literally in the brain
imaging it looks somewhat true but let's
think about this one for a moment so
you're going to be good at this if wine
a these are lines is longer than B and
line B is longer than line C is a longer
than C yes all right everything this is
MIT right all right now and answer this
question truly think about it for a
moment person a is a friend versus
person B so let's pretend you're person
being your friend was a and you're also
friend with C R a and C likely to be
friends let's think is it let's think
about this is it is it mathematically
transitive like this one
no let's think about it for a moment in
your experience through life on average
are your friends mostly kind of gonna
like each other kind of not all the time
a kind of yeah cuz probably because if
they like you if one person likes to
another person likes you you share
interest you share background to a
certain extent just in a loose
statistical way it's not definitive like
this so let's take a look what happens
when you ask these two questions grades
one through four okay these kids are
just making mistakes right and they're
getting smarter but look at this one
go up just like that so we can say this
is a growth in logical ability this is a
growth in your everyday sense that I
hang out with a certain kind of person
maybe they like football maybe they like
you know skating
you know maybe they like psychology
right but that's the group I tend to
hang out with and they on average you
know if I have a friend it's because we
share some interests or style of course
of being and if I have another friend we
probably share that too so more than
chance you know they might like each
other okay so so this is that idea that
you know there's you can separate out
what you might call purely logical
analysis of things versus sense a growth
of social experience basically so the
last three slides or so um you remember
this from a bit back from a prior
example we said there's a framing
heuristic if you're risk-averse for
gains your people are risk averse for
gains but the risk taking for losses to
it if we said here's program we did this
before a program is adopted 200 people
are saved and six and then or here's 400
people will die out of 600 that's the
same statement but because this is
stated as a pot as a gain people usually
like this because this is stated as a
loss people usually don't like this
adults are risk averse for gains and
their risk-taking for losses if
something looks like a loss roll the
dice something looks like it's going to
work out go with it even though
numerically these are identical turns
out that that attitude you can't see
this I can tell you is a not present in
preschoolers or second graders
preschoolers or second graders when
you're given these kinds of problems
they don't show the asymmetry for losses
and gains that's something that happens
over time and it's not a logical one
logically you should be that so in that
weird sense the preschooler is more
logical than you and I more logical than
you and I okay because there's no reason
to be statistically different for losses
and gains that's purely an attitudinal
emotional perspective so you could hear
the information-seeking
let's check it out that's kind of
interesting so Munna sharks that's kind
of you know that's kind of right I mean
I got sure you a 70 year olds we're not
gonna go
hey that could be kind of interesting
they're going on no terrible idea don't
do it okay yeah yes you see some pure
influence right yeah and that doesn't
happen without the lessons right back
all right so anyway so everybody don't
they do this they go oh my gosh these
are these teenagers are gonna go do all
these things and get horrible sexual
diseases and drive why they are impaired
and you know that's just the beginning
of the weekend okay
all right because they're not going to
follow all the advice that we gave them
for years and years and years and years
at home and in school so here's the flip
on this and just think about it for a
moment and it's complicated swimming
with sharks the adults say don't tell
you don't have to tell me anymore it's a
bad idea the gist is sharks bad okay I
don't even need to hear any of the rest
of the story adolescence starts to weigh
the factors we'd be safer in a group is
a dark or nights outside you know how
shallow is the water there and you could
say well it's kind of ridiculous but
it's not totally ridiculous because when
we talk about danger those are the kinds
of some of the things you might start to
think about so uh having you know so by
this analysis on having unprotected sex
adults you know bad a bad bad okay I
mean really bad I mean you're right
adolescence well let's think about this
oh you know that's what's the gain well
you know we hear that sex is highly
pleasurable ah what's the loss all these
things everybody is telling us what's
the odds purely statistically that for a
single sexual experience you will have
the pleasure of sex but you will end up
with a terrible disease what's the odds
for one outing what do you think
here's the complexity some people
arguing the adolescents are actually
more accurate in their assessment of
risk that lies in their choice okay do
you understand the point okay but
they're actually doing the calculation
whereas adults just go sharks bad
sexually transmitted diseases avoid okay
I guess we're you're not parsing through
the exact odds and circumstances the
trade-offs between exploration and
pleasure and responsibility and safety
you just have the gist the line that's
it that's my wisdom you know that I've
gotten sharks bad sexually transmitted
disease bad okay that's it uh and these
teenagers are kind of curiously thinking
about what are the factors you could say
it's not the best analysis but you could
say it's almost more rational just like
the older adults will make more just
errors in memory will be more emotional
in their avoidance of risk right okay so
so it's very complicated it's not just
dopamine flushing it's also in the brain
right it's also something about how risk
is perceived and understood of different
ages and what informations available to
you all right
thanks very much
you